- Cuz JPP was losing, he got a little upset.
He grabbed Prince and dunked him in the cold tub.
- [Laughing]
- Bro, when I tell you he dunked him in the cold tub, it was like, if Prince was this stick,
JPP had that guy over his head like this,
headfirst in the cold tub.
- [Laughing]
♪♪♪
- Justin Tuck! What's good with you, baby?
- I’m all good, boss. All good.
- How you doin’?
- Retired life, man, it’s pretty decent.
- Word on the streets is you workin’ where now?
- This place called Goldman Sachs
- “You know, somethin’ slight, you know what I’m saying?”
You need some more clients, like—
- Yeah, I do. Always.
- How much more do I gotta be making?
- It’s up there.
- [Laughing]
- So, Justin, everybody says
rappers wanna be ballplayers,
ballplayers wanna be rappers.
How is hip-hop culture immersed
when you were playing in the Giants?
- That statement is so true, just in the Giants locker room alone.
Every day we had rap battles,
whether that was one versus one,
a whole cypher—
whatever it may be, man
Listen, we did not care.
Anything was fair game, other than, like, obvious things, right?
You don’t talk about people’s wives and kids. But, like, your divorced wife,
she’s fair game.
- [Laughing]
- One of the bigger days in that kinda whole thing was
Osi and Stray.
It was kinda like a setup where
Osi was like the young bull trying to kick Strahan out of being the guy.
Like, Michael Strahan, Hall of Famer,
but Osi was, like, he had just signed his new deal.
Strahan had just gotten a divorce.
Literally they set up this rap battle with Stray and Osi.
Stray is just like, “Yo, it’s a rap battle. Whatever.
I’ll show up tomorrow and I’ll kick a few rhymes and be done.”
Osi took it so serious.
He went home that day and literally was, like, writing down rhymes, like—
- He was writing down lyrics?
- Testing them on—
I think he was testing them against people.
You know, his buddies and his girlfriend and all that.
“How this sound?”
Cuz he comes back the next day super confident.
- How you gon’ do that in a cypher though?
- Pfft, Osi a cheater, man.
- [Laughing]
- Osi cheat. Don’t ever play him in, like, FIFA, none of that, pool.
- He can’t come on the show then.
-Osi a cheat, man.
- Nah, man.
- So Osi came in cheating, prepared
with these Google lines that he did.
How was Strahan coming?
- So Stray had, like, one of those Mariah Carey golden mics.
He brings his golden mic in.
He brought it in in, like, a brown paper bag.
So Osi prepares a rhyme.
And, like, the rhyme had everything in it.
Talking about his new deal,
how he’s making more money than Stray now,
how he's kicking him out of the league.
- Wow.
- Basically saying, like,
his old wife didn’t want him, so the Giants don’t want him.
All of that.
We’re, like, crying laughing.
I knew it was gonna go there, cuz that's just how it is. We always went there.
But Stray was kinda caught off guard. You could see it in his face.
- [Laughing]
- Cuz he hadn’t prepared.
So he gets up, man, and, like,
he brings this old mic out
and just goes in on Osi.
- Starts spitting?
- Starts spitting.
To Stray’s credit, man, Stray’s witty, man. He’s quick with it.
He gets hooked up, man.
He starts talking about his deals and all the deals he’s signed.
Hall of Fame, talking about his cars, his houses.
He just broke LT’s all-time sack record for the Giants.
And ended it by saying, like, “Yeah,
I gave my wife a free trip to Disneyland,
gave her a few dollars, and she still got more than you.”
Basically it’s like he gave his ex-wife his chump change and
that money is still more money than what Osi just signed for.
I think Stray won that one
cuz he was, like, off the cuff.
- How did everybody respond to that?
- What?!” It was epic.
Everybody, like, gathered around the door and heard this.
It was like an epic scene of, like, people running down the halls, like, crying laughing.
- I’ve never heard of a team that would start a film review—
- That was every week.
We did some stuff, man, I can't share on here.
True untold stories
of stuff that—but, like, that’s just what we did to become a tighter group.
- JPP, Antrel Rolle.
What happened, bro?
- Don’t quote me on this, man, because—
- Nah, I’m quoting you on this. You on camera!
- But I think they were battling.
They were rap battling.
We had this rookie named Prince Amukamara.
I mean, he was always trying to get in it.
So instead of him just sitting back,
everytime Antrel said something or JPP said something,
he was that odd hype man that be like, “Oooh.”
Cuz JPP was losing, he got a little upset.
He grabbed Prince and dunked him in the cold tub.
- [Laughing]
- Bro, when I tell you he dunked him in the cold tub, it was like, if Prince was this stick,
JPP had that guy over his head like this,
headfirst in the cold tub.
We were actually doing him a favor.
Prince's legs gon’ be refreshed when he comes out of there.
- I did not expect that out of a Tom Coughlin team.
My whole perception as a Cowboys fan was just y'all were living that military lifestyle
and there was no fun, no play.
- Nah, I mean, that was the perception, man
But we had fun though, man. We had to.
- Oh, that’s it right there.
- Y'all see the hands.
- Good game, man.
- Oh, I got in there!